c'est bizarre ouais c'est quoi ça la
fumée perdre l'odorat quand on est
sommelière c'est comme perdre l'usage
d'un doigt quand on est pianiste j'ai eu
la covid le 26 avril autour du 29 avril
chantait plus rien
waouh au début je me disais ça va
revenir fait que j'étais pas angoissée
si l'amour peut nous rendre aveugle la
covid peut rendre anosmique et une plus
sentir veut aussi dire ne plus goûter
les mille et une saveurs contient
peut-être trop pour acquise
j'ai vraiment angoissé quand ça fait un
mois puis que là il y avait toujours
rien là c'est l'autre comment s'appelle
un peu plus
20% de la population a un problème avec
le rhodorat même avant la covid déjà et
dans la phase aiguë de la covidia
jusqu'à 60% des personnes qui ont une
perte de l'odorat assez profonde le
professeur frasnelli de l'Université du
Québec à Trois-Rivières étudie les liens
entre odorat et cerveau notamment en
trop de rats et fin poids santé mais
aussi humeur lorsque on mange des
aliments ou on ne des boissons on parle
dans le langage de tous les jours on
parle du goût c'est un bon goût un
mauvais goût mais en vérité c'est
surtout l'odorat qui est stimulé même
avec la bouche fermée parce que les
odeurs rendent dans le nez via la porte
arrière dans la foulée de la pandémie
des dizaines de personnes désemparées de
ne plus goûter leur plats favoris ont
participé à une étude menée par l'équipe
de l'UQTR pour tenter de comprendre
pourquoi le faction est affecté par la
covid si on pense que qui a perdu
l'odorat on va dire je sais pas si grave
tu plus les parfums tu sens plus les
fleurs oui c'est probablement pas si
important mais on perd toute cette
perception des aliments pour compenser
la perte de plaisir des anneaux SMIC
vont saler sucrés et pimenté plus
généreusement d'autres cherchent des
textures moelleuses ou encore
croustillantes pour se satisfaire
il y a aussi des gens qui se plaignent
altérations qualitative les odeurs ne
sont plus ce que elles devraient sentir
mais ça sent autre chose comme par
exemple la vanille ne sont plus la
vanille mais les pas sentir écouter le
caoutchouc brûlée
il faut que tu manges mais oui tu as
moins le goût de manger
[Musique]
dans la plupart des cas la parose mie
une modification de l'odorat ou
l'anosmie la perte totale sera
momentanée et pour guérir il faut
s'entraîner avec rigueur constance et
espoir on peut faire des exercices sur
plusieurs mois où on peut sentir des
odeurs catacistes odeurs qui ont sont
régulièrement
l'eau de rose la vanille l'eucalyptus le
citron ou quelque chose de même
et en laissant ses fioles une après
l'autre avec une narine avec l'autre
narine et on répète ça chaque matin
chaque soir peut-être encore plus et on
continue à faire ça pendant 12 semaines
trois mois à peu près ah c'est quoi donc
la vanille par exemple tu es capable de
sentir et de goûter le café pense à
autre chose de le sentir plus va pas
t'aider pamplemousse
[Musique]
la totalité de ses sens est revenue à la
normale un jour la science nous dira
peut-être si c'est l'entraînement qui
lui a permis de guérir ou simplement le
temps après cinq mois j'avais tout
retrouvé et après six mois j'étais
vraiment confiante que là tout y était
c'est aussi un soulagement parce que en
fait c'est que ça confirme ton amour
pour ce que tu fais quand on a
l'impression ou la peur qu'on te
l'enlève si tu te mets à paniquer tu dis
mais qu'est-ce que je vais faire c'est
c'est ma vie au delà du métier c'est de
sentir les fleurs dehors c'est c'est de
sentir le pain qui sort du four c'est un
plaisir de la vie que c'est super ça
c'est la vie est beaucoup moins colorée
et beaucoup moins intéressant la bonne
nouvelle c'est que de la dent de la
majorité des cas ça revient mais
malheureusement il y a quand même un
pourcentage important des gens qui ont
des problèmes de de troubles de l'odorat
à long terme